[موسيقى]
سرطان وثدي كلمتان حين تلتقيان تكون
الصدمه مزدوجه مرض خبيث لا يهاجم الصحه
وحسب بل يق تحم عوالم الانوثه بمفاهيمها
السائده كيف لا وفي المراه انعكاس لجسد
اضناه العلاج واخافه الوصمه وفي المراه
انعكاس لوجه حزين ويدين تتحسس راسا حليقه
افقدت
شعرها امراه بدون ثدي وبدون شعر كيف ترى
نفسها وكيف يراها شريكها ان وجد ماذا عن
محيطها الاجتماعي هل هو المسؤول عن شعورها
بنقص ما
وهلان اوان الحرب على صور النمطيه باليه
تلخص النساء باثداء هن وخصلات شعرهن سرطان
الثدي في فلك الممنوع كانت الخبريه كانت
كثير صعبه علي وما تقبلتها ابدا ابدا كنت
لحالي زوجي مسافر وكنت عم اكذب حالي انه ل
ليه صار معي هيك وقضيتها بكي ما انام ما
اكل ما اقدر احكي مع حدا ما اتقبل اي كلمه
من حدا
لحد ما انه دقيت لزوجي و حطيته بالصوره
وقلت له القصه واح ا 3 وطلبت منه انه اذا
بيقدر يجي يكون موجود قبل العمليه ول
بالال ما بلش بالعلاج
مرضي قال اعملي العمليه وان شاء الله خير
قلبي كان حسسني انه في شيء غلط بالموضوع
قلت
اتصالاته صار رفع عتب يسال او يحكي او او
يطمن حتى خلصنا العمليه بلشت بالكيم اول
جلسه ثاني جلسه بلشت طبعا التغيرات على
جسمي بلش شوي يهر شعري انا قمت جبت م كانت
الحلاقه
وحلقت شعري اطلعت بالمرايه وضحكت ما
اهتميت ما تاثرت اضحكت طلعت بشكلي وضحكت
قلت يلا هيك اريح و واخف كان كل همي
ال الاوجاع اتخطى هالاو جاع والالام
وهالمره اللي انا فيها وهون اجا زوجي كنت
تقريبا بالجلسه
الرابعه كنت شكلي جسديا كله مغير طبعا ما
في حواجب ما في رموش ما في شعر كليا نصحت
مش كثير يعني بس انه تغير شكل جسمي طبعا
بتعرفوا لون البشره وهيدا كنت بيني وبين
نفسي اقول هي كله بروح كله بيرجع كله
بيتحسن المهم انه نشفى ونتخطى هالمرحله ها
بس للاسف الاصعب من الصراع مع المرض ومع
الالم والوجع كان عندي صراع ثاني اللي
واجهته
اي زوجي قرر انه ينفصل عني بسبب المرض ما
بسبب شيء ثاني
ا هيك من
دون بدون مقدمات بدون شيء وتم الطلاق
وفصلنا كانت تلك شهاده لسيده لبنانيه فضلت
انلا تكشف عن هويتها عمرها 55 عاما تم
تشخيصها بسرطان الثدي في ربيع عام 2021
ورم حجمه 5 سنتيمترات في ثديها الايمن
اجبر الاطباء على استئصاله بشكل كامل قبل
دخولها معركه العلاج الكيميائي وعلاج
الاشعه هذه السيده حاربت على عده جبهات
جبهه السرطان وجبهه زوج انفصل عنها بسبب
مرضها فبعد تشخيصها ببضعه اشهر تلقت
اتصالا من المحكمه الجعفريه لاعلامه بان
زوجها قد طلقها لكن ولحسن الحظ الناس لا
يتشابهون ضيفنا الاول فقد زوجته بسبب
سرطان الثدي فقرر تاسيس جمعيه باسمها
جمعيه بربره نصار التي تعنى بمرضى السرطان
سيد هاني نصار اهلا بك من كاليفورنيا لم
تترك زوجتك ولا لحظه خلال مرضها كنت يعني
الى جانبها في كل اللحظات حتى النهايه كيف
تصف رجل يطلق زوجته لانها مصابه بسرطان
الثدي انا هيك اشخاص صراحه ما في اتخيلهم
يعني وقت يتزوجوا اثنين تزوجوا على الحلوه
وع المره مش على الحلوه بكون حد بعضنا وع
المره بنترك بعض بس للاسف انه في كثير
اشخاص بتيجي بتقوللك انه انا ما بدي اكون
ممرض او انا ما تزوجتها بهذه الطريقه انا
دائما كان جوابي انه اذا انت صارلك هيك هي
شو راح تعمل انا بربره اكيد ما كانت ح
تتركني كانت تبقى
حدي وما عندي خيار ثاني بمل ارادتي الا ان
يكون حد طيب اعود معك الى البدايه هل كنت
مع بربره عندما اخبرها الاطباء باصابتها
كيف تتذكر لحظه الاعلان اللي صار معنا انه
انكسرت رقبتها ل بربره ورحنا على المستشفى
وبلشنا فحوصات من فحص لفحص اكتشفنا انه هي
بالمرحله الاخيره بالمرض ا اكيد انا يعني
بربرا 24 على 24 انا واياها ا وكنا سوا
بنعرف كل شيء طبيعي يعني ولا مره كانت هي
تتلقى خبر انا ماكون حدها ا حتى اولادنا
الاثنين اللي كان امرهم 10 سنين وتسع سنين
ليوني وليون هم كانوا مصرين انه يعرفوا كل
شيء ونحن جبنا كعيبه لروحها السلام لروحها
السلام يا هاني من عمان في الاردن
الدكتوره نغم القرغولي الاستشاريه في
الجراحه العامه والثدي والمنظار دكتوره
نغم اهلا بك ما اكثر ما هو ملفت في تعامل
شركاء النساء المتزوجات مع اصابه زوجاتهم
بسرطان الثدي هل هناك ردود فعل اثارت
انتباهك ربما اكثر من غيرها مع مريضات لك
و مع شركائه بدايه شكرا انه في برنامج زي
هيك الناس تقدر توصل صوتها وان كثير عندي
سيدات خصوصا بهذا الجزء من مجتمعنا
بجوز يوروب مختلف شوي عن عندنا هون احنا
ا اللي بنلاحظ انه الست اول ما هي لما
تيجي بتكون لما تسمع كلمه سرطان بتكون
مفكره انه هذا يعني موت فلذلك احن كثير
بنشتغل على موضوع التوعيه وبضل نذكرهم انه
بالعكس انه انتم كل ما تكشفوا ابكر كل ما
كانت الامور اسهل وانه م تحطوا هذا
المرض لكن من اللي مرق علينا اول شيء
بتفكر فيه السيده هو عيلتها امم قبل نفسها
ف لذلك كان في احدى حتى حركات التوعيه انه
انه انت اول او افحصي وطمنينا لانه بما
لانه هم يعني عم حاولوا بي حركه التوعيه
يجوا على النقطه اللي بتلمس بقلبها الجزء
الاكبر اللي هي عيلتها يعني احن عارفين
كيف السيدات لما احن بنقابلهم اثناء
العلاج فهي اول شيء بتفكر فيه هو بيتها
وعيلتها واولادها بناتها دراستهم المستقبل
وزوجها طيب ف ما مدى اهميه لحظه التشخيص
دكتوره والاعلان عن هذا التشخيص لمصابه
يعني كيف تنقلين هذا الخبر وهل تفضلين ان
يكن مع شريك في حال كنا متزوجات او مع احد
افراد العائله طبعا هي اللحظه كثير مهمه
اي انا حتى قبل ما نخطط للحلقه كنت عم
بحكي مع ال قسم الانتاج ف كنت عمعم بحكي
بعض الامثله اللي مرت علي ليش مهمه كثير
هي الطريقه يعني انا في عندي ناس بونوا
تشخص مثلا بمكان اخر وبيجوا عندي على
العياده بس عشان يسمعوا كلمتين اطمنهم
اكيد انا باكد على ضرور ضروريه واهميه انه
ضروره واهميه انه يكون معها على الاقل
زوجها اولا عشان لما تكون الصدمه عليها
اول ما نحن نحكي في الموضوع كل حدا يخفف
عنها هي بدايه هنا في استديو باريس ارحب
برئيسه تجمع اللبنانيين العلمانيين في
فرنسا والباحث في العلوم الاجتماعيه
والنشطه السياسيه السيده رولا يحيى اهلا
بك رولا اهلا بك يعني انت
محاربه لازلت تحاربين السرطان هذا السرطان
الذي دخل عبر الثدي الى جسدك دخل عام
2004م وتغلبت عليه حينها و
وهجم وانتشر مؤخرا وانت اليوم في مرحله
العلاج المستمره يعني انت في الجوله
الثانيه وتقومين وتحارب ونحن نتمنى لك
الشفاء التام
شكرا يعني اسمحي لي واعرف ان هذا ربما قد
يكون مؤلما ولكن اريد ان اعود معك الى اول
لحظه تم تشخيصك بها
بالمرض كيف تم
اخبارك ما كان هذا الشعور هل كنت لوحدك هل
شعرتي ربما بخجل في الحديث عن هذا المرض
في المحيط ربما لانه الثدي
ربما ابدا بالعكس يعني اولا كنت
لوحدي اولادي كانوا طبعا
بالمدارس و كيف عرفتي كان هناك عوارف اول
لا اول مره كنت عم
بتحمم خلال الاستحمام شعرت بشيء ورم ام
كتله كتله ام ا اعتقدت ان هناك الدي
الايمن ام الايسر لا بال بالايسر بالايسر
اوك كنت توقعت انه يمكن يكون في صابون
مجمع بقلب الجان بهيدا بالليفه التي نقوم
ب نعم اطلع شلت ايدي وصرت اطلع ما في شيء
ساعتها حسيت ب انه في شيء منه طبيعي اتصلت
بحكيمي كنا باخر اب وحكيم الطبيب كان
بالعطله الصيفيه ا يعني غشت اغسطس نعم ايه
وفجاه
بقدر الاقي واحد بنفس العياده موجود فطلبت
منه قلت له انه هيك هيك عم بصير انه حسيت
في شيء ومرتي دفا فحصني دغري هو بيقول لي
بدي ابعثك قاللي عامله ماموغرافي قريبا
قلت له بحياتي ما عامله ماموغرافي انا
الصوره للثدي اللي هي الصوره التي يعني
ندعو جميع النساء في عمر معين الى القيام
بها حتى يعني اكيد انا انا ندمت بعدين
لانه ك كنت اشوف اصحاب لكنك كنت شابه كم
يعني كم كان عمرك يعني الاربعينات يعني
اول الاربعينات
تقريبا لا بنصف الثاني من الاربعينات
اي بال 2004 هالشيء
صار ولما قال لي الحكيم انه دغري بده
يبعثني لاعمل هيدا بلشت شك انه قلت انا
معقوله انه قبل هلا في مره حكيم قال لي
هدول لانه عندك انت غدد باله فافتكرتك شي
غدي فلما عملت الفحوصات ورجعت لعنده بيطلع
هيك ب
اللي بدي ابعثك على مستشفى بيحمل السماعه
انتبهت انا انه انا لوحدي وبربي ادي لوحدي
ما معي حدا لانه انا يعني قال لك انت
مصابه بسرطان الثدي ما ما كان عم ققول لي
بعد بس عم بيقول لي انه بدي اتصل بمستشفى
لانه بدنا نعمل فحوصات اعمق من اللي
عملتيها ام فبلا قيه عم بيحكي قلت له طب
لانه ما بيعرفني هو قلت له انا بربي ادي
لوحدي وما معي حدا و وحتى اهلي مش موجودين
بباريس عندي بنت خالي وحيده هون بس ما
معها وقت كثير وهيك فبقوم قلت له ما لقيته
غير بيسكر السماعه بيرجع بيطلع الدفتر
وبيطلع رقم ثاني هون بيتصل بالانسي كوري
معهد مستشفى معهد كوري اي
ف بياخذ لي موعد من مع احسن حكيم فهمت انت
ان هناك لما ايه دغري فهم دغري فهمت هلا
هو لاحظ علي اني انا شكيت بالامر فبقوم
بيطلع
روشه بيعمل يعني وفه وصفه وبيعطي اياها عم
بطلع فيها هيك بقرا ليكزوميل طلعت فيها
هيك قلت له مهدئ ايه قلت له لشو هيدا قال
لي لانه اكيد بدك تحسي انه يمكن بحاجه
لانك بالتوتر او يمكن قبل ما تنامي او شيء
قلت له دكتور طبيب انت عم تعلن لي
مشكل بدك ياني اوقع ب مشكل اني اللي هو
انه صير عندي دب يعني شعرتي بالخوف للحظه
ما عندما فهمتي انه سرطان اكيد شعرت اكيد
حسيت مش مش بس هيك انه انا لوحدي مع
اولادي فكرتي باطفال كما قال الدكتوره نغم
يعني اول ما فكرت به هو ولديك لما سمعت عم
تحكي هيك يعني دغري تذكرت حالي لانه انا
نفس الشيء صار معي يعني لم تفكري بجسدك
بجسدك ع
بالثدي يعني حتى وقت اللي الحك لما رحت
على مستشفى كير وتاك اكد انه في سرطان
واعلن لي انه بده يعمل قال لي لانه يمكن
يكون مغلغل بالجسم فبنا نعمل
استئصال السدي
اي قال
لي بدك ترتاحي شوي بعدين بكمل قلت له ما
في لزوم انه ارتاح لي لم يكن لديك وقت كنت
تفكرين باطفالك ايه بعدين انه انه قلت له
يمكن لو عم تقول لي بدك تشل لي ارجر بدك
تشل لي ايد بس انه السدي ما رح يقدم وياخر
عن طيب قلت له انه انا اولادي كبروا
ومرضعته وما عندي بقى اولاد وخلص انه ما
عندي اولاد سعودي لهذه النقطه معك بعد
قليل دعينا نتعرف الى ضيفتنا الرابعه
والاخيره من تونس العاصمه دكتوره ريم
الرباعي الطبيبه المتخصصه في الطب الجنسي
اهلا بك دكتوره ريم انت ايضا تحاربين
سرطان الثدي منذ مده وحاليا في مرحله
التعافي نتمنى لك الشفاء التام دكتوره
تتحدثين عن المرض بدون تبوه كيف تلقيت خبر
الاصابه صحيح المرض تلقي الخبر اعه ما
كانش سهل بالنسبه
ليلي بما اني
انا بنت المجال الطبي نعمل الماموغرافي
اعي سنويا وال ماموغرافي ديما تطلع عاديه
ما فيها حتى مرض نعمل ماموغرافي خطر عندي
وراثه في العائله في مرض السرطان طلقي
الخبر كان ماهوش ساهل على خاطر كانت عندي
اهداف عباره على انسان ماشي في طريق سياره
طويله وعنده اهداف بعيده المدى نحكي على
20 سنه الى الامام على 30 سنه الى الامام
فجاه ك نتلقاو الاخبر
هذا نجد انفسنا ك ترمينا في طريق اخر
اهداف فيه متها ليميت ثلاثه اشهر اربعه
اشهر ست اشهر صعيبه ماهيش ساهله محدوده
محدوده المدا ومحدوده المفاهيم وبالاخص ك
تبدا عننا اطفال في سن صغير برشا واحنا
نبداو احنا اللي نرعاهم واحنا اللي نحبوا
نعمل لهم كل شي
بطبيعتنا دونك السوتيان العائلي معنتها
الدعم العائله مع العائله كان فال دعم
العائله وجنود الخفاء برشا عننا العائله
والاصحاب كانوا ديما متواجدين وكل عبد كان
يدخل في حياتي عنده معناتها رول معين
وعنده بلاصه معينه وكل في كل مرحله من
مراحل بتبيعه انا من الاول عرفت اللي يلزم
استئصال ثدي باش يكون دونك من الاول ما
قبلتها صحيح بالرغم اني من مجال معناتها
من الميدان الطبي و
و قرت روحي ب انجلينا جولي وهذاك ما تقبلت
ما تقبلت انت جميله جدا على اي حال يعني
مع ليست لوحدها جميله انجلينا نعم طيب لم
تتقبلي فكره الاستئصال ماذا فعلتي حاولتي
ان
يعني حاولت حاولت نمشي بش نعمل رو
كونكسيون ايديات متها بش نركب الثدي اخرم
الثدي هذاك وقت اللي مشيت للطب طبيب
التجميل اعي حسيت روحي مانيش باش نحي
الثدي على خاطر عندي سرطان حسيت روحي باش
نحي الثدي على خاطر باش نجمل في الصوره
الجسديه اعي من وقت خذت ديسيون معنتها
قررت اني نستاصل الثديين معا ونرم كيف كيف
نعم دونك بعد منها تمت معنتها منول معها
ماقبلتش زياده اني نشوف نعم لم تقبلي ان
ان تكوني بدون ثدي في مرحله ما قمتي بهذا
الخيار لانك تحبين ربما ان تكوني بهذا
الشكل وهذا حقك ولكن هذا يدفعنا الى سؤال
اخر اليوم ارتباط السرطان بالثدي وارتباط
الثدي بانوثه المراه بالجنس بالخصوبه يعقد
الامور كثيرا ربما لدى المصابات هل هو ما
يعطي الشعور احيانا بالحياء بالخجل من
التحدث عن هذا المرض
صحيح سرطان الثدي بش ياثر على حياتنا في
برشا مجالات الخصوبه اي على خاطر بعض حصص
الكيمياوي سو كي تبدا المراه مع عندهاش
صغار مازالت تزوجت دونك باش تخمم انها
كيفاش باش تعمل خطر
الكيمياوي معها يقلل ياثر
برشا حاليا معها الطب تقدم وتقع معناتها
التجميد
زفوي البويضات طيب دعيني فقط استفيد من
وجود السيد هاني معنا بما انه يعني مر
بهذه التجربه كشريك لاسال عن الجانب
المتعلق بهذه النظره اليوم وربط ثدي
المراه ربما بانوثتها انت كشريك هل يعني
هل فكرت من هذه الناحيه هل هناك اص وقت
للتفكير في هذه الناحيه عندما تكون
الشريكه مريضه ولماذا اليوم نرى بعض
الرجال او بعض الشركاء ربما يركزون على
هذه المساله ما يجعل المراه اصلا في مكان
ما تشعر بضيق او بهم بسبب هذا
الموضوع هلا ما فينا نقول انه ما في وقت
نفكر بهذا الموضوع بس انه مرض السرطان
بخليكي اكثر تفكري بجوهر معنى الحياه اكثر
بتبطلي تتعلقي بالخشوع بس بالنتيجه نحن
بشر ما فينا نقول انه لا مش لازم نفكر
بهذا الموضوع او ممنوع او ما
بحقنا بس هون قديش انت
بتكوني
بتكوني يعني تتغاضي عن هذا الموضوع اكثر
لحتى تقدر تتخطي هذه المرحله بطريقه اسلس
يعني نحن مثلا انا بربره بالرغم من كل
قوتها كانت بس عمده العمليه تبعها كانت
هيك شوي حزينه شوي ق لها انا انه شو بك
تقول لي انه عم بفكر فيك قلت لها انا
اخذناها دائما كنا ناخذ القصص بروح النكته
قلت ل هلا انت صار عندك واحد طبيعي وواحد
حطى في سيليكون اذا كرمالي انا وقت اللي
بدي طبيعي في طبيعي وقت بدي في سلي ف كنا
نقطع الامور بهذه الطريقه بس انه ببعض
المراحل يعني حتى ما كانت بدها تطلع
بالمرايه يعني برجع بقول يعني بربره نحن
يلي بيعرفها مزبوط بيعرف عرف قصتنا وشو
عملت قول هذ انسانه جبيره جدا ما ممكن
تفكر بهذا الموضوع لا حتى هي كان عندها
هذا هذا امر انساني طبعا ولها الحق ولكل
سيده الحق وهذا جسد السيده يعني اليوم
المشكله مع هذا مع هذا المرض بالتحديد انه
ينتهك حرمه الجسد وايضا يسائل مفهوم
الانوثه اصلا يعني في المجتمعات التي نعيش
بها في كل العالم دكتوره نغم كيف يتفاعل
الشريك مع مساله الاستئصال يعني هل يؤثر
اصلا على شعور المراه يعني مثلا هاني
استمعت اليه هاني كان داعما لزوجته ورغم
ذلك شعر بحزنها ما هي اهميه هذا هذا الشق
في في العلاج وفي رحله مكافحه
السرطان هلا طبعا هذا الاشي كثير مهم يعني
كورنر ستون يعني كورنر ستون بسموه زي حجر
اساس يعتبر
مهم طبعا في كثير
رجال بيكملوا مع السيده هذا مشوار ودعموها
وبيساعد انها تتخطى عليه لانه نحن بنعرف
من ناحيه طبيه وعلميه قديش اهميه انه جهاز
المناعه يكون باحسن حالاته به الفتره لانه
ضعف في جهاز المناعه به الفتره ممكن ياثر
بشكل سلبي على المرض وشده المرض او انها
تتخطى حتى علاج المرض او الكيمياوي اللي
بتاخذه فاحن بيكون عندنا نوعين طبعا من من
اللي شفته من البراكتس في منه اللي بدعم
زوجته بيكون معها وفي منه اللي بيكون معها
بالبدايه وبعدين بيسحب حاله في عده اسباب
في منها جهل وهو انه بفكر مثلا مرض
السرطان الثدي معدي للاسف
اي وفي منهم ناس بالنسبه له انه هي بطلت
انها قادره انها تكون سيده مثلا لانه احن
يعني عضو الثدي هو زي يمثل الخصوبه
والانوثه بعض الرجال بيطلعوا عليه زي ك
انه قدرتها على الانجاب مش بالرحم وبالم
بايض بالثدي ف بتعرفي هي ث اوت ذا هيستوري
يعني مفاهيم خاطئه وصور نمطيه وربما شيء
انا لجسد المراه ايضا يعني
يعني نعم تفضلي كملي بتلاقي انه زي هذول
الناس مثلا انه بقرر مثلا يتزوج عن او
مثلا يطلقها انه خلص احنا لهون لازم انه
يعني كما كما راينا في الشهاده التي
عرضناها في بدايه الحلقه طيب قبل ان نكمل
نقاشنا نذهب في جوله البعض العواصم في دول
عربيه حيث سالنا المواطنات والمواطنين
لماذا الحرج في الحديث عن سرطان الثدي
بالتحديد الينا واليكم
الاجابات المرض ما في منه خجل يعني المرض
من عند ربنا وكل انسان اي معرض للمرض اول
ما بمس بمس انوثه المراه بشكل عام فهذا
الموضوع بيكون كثير سنستيف وكثير بيكون
لها شيء كثير حرج وللاسف هي نظره خلقها
المجتمع او ربطها المجتمع بهذا المرض
بالرغم من انه لو كان السرطان بعضو اخر ما
كنا رح نكون هالقد عننا قلق او تخوف او
خجل من انه نعترف بهذا المرض انا على
العكس تماما بقول هذا
يعني نوع من انواع التخلف لانه هذا مرض
عادي جدا ويجب علاجه هذا الشيء مش عار ومش
بيهدد من انوثتها ولا بقلل من امومتها او
قدرتها على الانجاب او انها تكون زوجه
المراه بصوره خاصه انه هي راح تعاني من
هذا الم
جه يعني من الحاله النفسيه وم المجتمع
بصوره عامه اقرب الانسان يعني من اقرب
الاسان انها راح تعاني منه الم ليش تستحل
استح مات يعني لا حياه بالطيب يعني
المفروض احنا قبل فوات الاوان نروح يعني
ها حياه وموت خ المجتمع رجولي بالحق س هو
مرض كرض الكلح بصراحه حتى الر يقتلهم
البنات م هما صغارك حاجه معناها تحشم
مايلزمك تحكي عليها فهمت تسك زون هكا
معناها في بدنك لازمك تخبيها وما تحكيش
عليها دونكس ف حاجات في البدن تقعد ديما
محرمه في مجتمعات للاسف الوغ بالعكس زمها
هي تتكلم وتحكي على المرض اعها تعاون برشا
نساء اللي بش يمشوا ههم يعدوا ويعملوا
ماموغرافي ويعملوا ديز اناليز باش يعرفوا
ويمس بززهم وسوا تحت ضبطها ما يلقو نجلد
ولا حاجه هك يعاونوا المجتمع
رائعه هذه السيده
رولا انت تتكلمين عن مرضك بدون خجل
تتكلمين عن العلاج كانت هذه يعني اشاهد
احيانا تضعين يعني مستجدات ما حدث معك هل
تفعلين هذا الامر عمدا ام انك بحاجه ربما
لفعله هل كسرت خجلا ما ام لم تكوني خجوله
بهذا المرض ولا لحظه لانك ربما هنا في
فرنسا او ربما حتى في فرنسا هناك بعض
التبو كمان يعني
الناسي ايه
لانه يعني بس انا يمكن سابني حظ انه المحل
اللي بشتغل فيه مكان عملي في ناس يعني
مطلعين اكثر وهيك فبتكون كنت ممثله كمان
عن ال زملائي
الموظفين نقابيا وكان وقت عم نحضر
اجتماعات لنحكي بالمتقاعدين مع فقلت انا
كيف بدي اكمل وبدي الحق هيك فرحت طلبت
موعد من الديار اش يعني المسؤول المسؤول
عن الموارد البشريه و وسالت قلت له فيك
تضبط المواعيد ال الاجتماعات بحيث اذهب
الى العلاج وقت بكون عندي شيل كيمائي ما
تعمل لي عم طلعوا في هيك قال لي
ا في زميله لنا كمان وضعها مثل وضعك يعني
انا ما كنت عارفه هديك الزميله ابدا ولا
مره ح انا وياها بعدين على طول مثلا بتلبس
كانت اكمام طويله هلا لحظي اذا بتشوفوا في
فرق بال بالحجم بين ايد وايد بسبب العلاج
هي لا هي بسبب انه سحبوا الغدد بسبب الغدد
التي حيث استقد حيث استؤصل ف بتصير ما
فيها امونتي ش بالعربي المناعه فبص اي شيء
اي جرح بورقه ب ممكن تلتهب لانه يمكن
الجرح بسكين بنتبه له اكثر نحن عم نقطع
شيء لانه بطلع دم بينم جرح الورقه ما
بنتبه وانا بشتغل كثير بالكتب وهي مهنت
يعني فلما اجرح اصبعي ما انتبه تلتهب ايدي
ف يعني بنعمل لها كل اسبوع جلسه لحتى يرجع
بيعملوا لها دريناج ل مهم ان نتحدث عن هذه
الامور رولا هي مهم مهم ان يعرف الناس
اليوم ما هي رحله كيف يبدا سرطان الثدي
كيف يمكن ان يتحول كما حصل معك اليوم انت
يعني وانشر مهم ان نتحدث
برايك وور ايه ايه لازم لانه لازم يعني
الناس ما تخاف انه تفكر انه يعني خلص اذا
صار معي سرطان ما بسترجي احكي ما بقدر
يمكن في منهم يمكن توصل معهم القصه حسب ما
بعض الاحيان للانتحار انه ما بدي انه يصير
في هالشيء بعدين في ناس مثلا بتقول لك لا
اصحك بتقولي للكلمه يعني تمسكين بالحياه
ولا انت انت تتمسكين بالحياه اكيد انا
مبسوطه كثير انه لما صار معي سرطان اول
مره كانت عندي ولدين طبعا ابني كان اكبر
بس بنتي لانها كانت عمر 10 سنين وبعدها
بالخر سنه بالابتدائي صرت بس اول يا الله
انا بس لحتى لي تخلص بنت البكالوريا لانه
شغله مهمه كانت بالنسبه لي امي ربتنا ماما
كانت هي من مؤسسه تجمع المراه اللبنانيه
وكانت تشارك بمؤتمرات وكل شيء وكانت على
طول يعني اي مراه بتشوفها اي جاره اي لازم
الاولاد يتعلموا خاصه ا بدي بنتي تتعلم
خفت يصير علي شي قبل ما بنتي تق تتعلم
وتعلمت وكبرت وتجوزت وصار عندها هلا بيبي
يعني صارت هلا جده وانت جده اليوم وانا
كنت خوفان كان عمر 10 سنين بقت الليل عمر
الطويل يا رولا حبيبتي بس ضروري ضروري
الحكي لانه يمكن يشجع الناس انه بضلني انا
على القليله بواصل حياتي على الامل ربما
وايضا على ضروره ضروره التشخيص طول نتفا
دكتوره ريم هناك ايضا يعني في مساله سرطان
الثدي بالتحديد هناك كل ما يتعلق بالعلاقه
الحميمه بين المراه والرجل
اليوم ربما من الصعب جدا ان نتحدث عن هذه
الامور حتى هنا في فرنسا يعني هو هذا
التابو ربما
الاكبر هل هل سبق ربما انت شخصيا ان طرحت
هذا السؤال على نفسك او ان طرح من
قبل يعني يعني مريضات او مصابات قابلتهن
من خلال
عملك هو تبوء ماهوش بالضروره
مرتبط بوجود السرطان
ولادي تبو في مادام مصالحه المراه مع
الجسد متاعها اسك هي متصالحه مع روحها ولا
لا اسك المراه هذ تنجم تغزر روحها قدام
المرايه ولا
صعيب ياسر باش مراه تتصالح من الاول في
المراحل الاولى اع العلاج خطر ماهيش قابله
نفسها والمراه ما تقبلش انه شريك حياتها
والا زوجها في اول علاقه حميميه بعد
انتهاء العلاج مش يغزر لها غزره غير عاديه
يعني المراه باش تولي معناتها عن طريق
نظره زوجها ولا شريكها ليله هي باش تغزر
روحها اذا كان هو غزر لها بكل حب وتفاؤل
ويزيد يرفع لها من معنوياتها ويخليها تحس
اللي هي امراه خطر المراه عمرها ما كان
جسد المراه هي الروح نعم اذا كان يحسسها
بالانوثه اعها في العلاقه
معها اكيد هي باش تحب روحها واكيد هي باش
تغزل روحها مراه مزيانه برشا واكيد باش
تغزر روحها هي معنتها مخلوق عادي اما اذا
كان الراجل وصل غزر نسس هكا ولا نظره
نفور بابسط حاجه من المراه هذك سي فقدت
الثقه التامه بنفسها
وتها انها بش تبني ا دور دور الشريك كراس
بش تسكر على
روحها تفضلي كملي وماعاش بش تقبل الزوج
متاعها وماعاش تقبل وبش ننجم توصل حتى
تكره الجنس الرجالي بصفه عامه
دونك اذا دور المحيط دور الشريك دور
الشريك في انه يقبلها ودور المحيط كمان
الاجتماعي سنتحدث عنه معك هاني دكتوره نغم
قبل ان تغادرنا لانه رجب ان تغادر يعني
اريد ان اسالك عن مساله ال العمر ربما عمر
المصابه انا
يعني اعتذر يعني ساتحدث بشكل شخصي لاول
مره ولكن جدتي اصيبت بسرطان الثدي وكانت
يعني كبيره في السن جدا ولكن كان يعني
لاقت صعوبه شديده في النظر الى ثديها بعد
الاستئصال اليوم هل مساله السن تلعب دور
لدى السيده المصابه هل ربما ترينا قدره
اكبر على التقبل لدى الاصغر سنا ام
لا الجواب لا بالعكس انا توقعتك رح
تساليني بالعكس رح تقولي لي هل انه بيكون
اصعب على الاصغر عمرا انه رح يتم ازاله
الثدي والاكبر عمرا ممكن نعتبره انه اخف
او عادي الجواب لا صغيره او كبيره الثدي
هو الثدي بالنسبه لهم هو يمثل الخصوبه
للسيدات وللرجال يعني حتى السيده نفسها من
غير تاثير اي رجل او زوج او حدا خال
لطار انه يعمل عمليات الترميم في بعض
الحالات ايبل يعني يتم استئصال ثم الترميم
مباشره مش انه بعد فتره ان كانت الحاله
طبعا تسمح وذلك بسبب ها العوامل
النفسيه الترميم هو جزء من الحل اليوم
للسيدات اللواتي يعني يتعافي هو جزء من
الحل الشق النفسي مهم اي هو بدايه كعمليه
كانت زمان ببريطانيا هي اول عمليه كانت
استصال الثدي بطريقه كانت جدا عنيفه انه
اعتقاد الجراحين نن بتعرفي العلم هو
بيتطور انه اذا ازلنا الثدي وال والطبقات
الجسم اللي تحتيه مع حتى جزء من عظام
القفص الصدري والعضلات في المنطقه اذا
عملنا هي الطريقه فهو ممكن انه نسبه رجوعه
اقل كل الدراسات اثبتت بغض النظر عن
الطريقه المتبعه بالجراحه مرض سرطان الثدي
هو مرض سستمك يعني بيصيب الجسم كله من
بدايته لذلك لازم نكشف عنه في بدايته
فتغيرت العمليه من كانت زي بهذا العنف الى
استئصال فقط الكتله وما حواليها بحاجه
استئصال العقد اللمفاويه الموجوده في
الذراع بالجهه المصابه من من الى فهذا اول
شيء بالحل بدال مثلا الاستئصال كامل وال
الثاني اللي هو الترميم اللي ممكن انه
يكون اون تيبل بنفس الوقت من عمليه الاص
كلمه اخيره لك دكتوره نغم قبل ان تغادرين
ماذا تقولين اليوم لسيدات يعني بشكل عام
بمساله سرطان الثدي كطبيبه
متخصصه انا بدي احكي كبنه لسيده اصيبت
بسرطان الثدي انا ما حكيت لكم هذا الشي
قبل ما تحكوا معي تليفون انا والدتي الله
يحميها تشخص عن طريق السكرين الروتين
سكرين ما كان شيء اي عشانها هي حست بكتله
وراحت شكت لا بما اني انا بنتها جراحه
فلازم نحن نكشف شكل دوري فاكتشفنا صدفه
وكان طبعا صدمه لكن والدتي كانت قويه
والحمد لله قدرنا انه احنا نعتبر من
الناجين خلال السنتين اللي فاتوا هذا
الرساله اللي بدي اوصلها بدال ما احن نكون
ضحايا لهيك مرض شرس ما بيفرق ما بين كبير
او صغير ما بين ذكر او انثى يعني في ذكور
حتى ياح هدول مظلومين لانهم ما كونوا
عارفين انه هم ممكن يتشخص بسرطان الثدي
وبعدين انهم تخصوا وهدول تبوه اكثر لانه
هو رجل كيف يعني انه اصابه سرطان في فدي
فرسالتي انه بدال ما احنا نكون ضحايا احنا
بنكون منتصرين احنا بكون قدوه لغيرنا احنا
بنكمل حياتنا بشكل الكشف المبكر اذا الكشف
المبكر
تمام تمام شكرا لك دكتوره ساسال هاني سؤال
فيما يتعلق بكل ما استمعت اليه الان يعني
مساله المسانده النفسيه انت كيف لعبت في
تجربتك مع بربره هل بالنسبه اليك كانت
احدثت فارقا مساله وجودك ووجود عائلتها
الى جانبها في هذه التجربه
ا هي لعبه كل الفرق بربارا وقت
شخصت بسرطان الثدي مع انتقالات وتكسير
بالعظم قالوا لنا حطونا بجو بالمستشفى انه
اذا الله بحبنا بتعيش سنه بعد خمس سنين
سالوها شو السر انك عشتي خمس سنين مش سنه
قالت لهم الحب هو العلاج الاهم للمرض يعني
وقت اللي انت اليوم من بعد سنه من ما
حكونا هذا الحكي عملنا شيء اسمه رحله
العالم اللبناني يعني برمنا
1655 ضيعه بلبنان لبنان بالرغم من كل
التكسير بالرغم كل التكسير يلي موجود
بجسدها بكفون قاطره ومقطوره قعدنا 80 يوم
مرجع نا فيهم على البيت عم نجمع تواقيع من
خطير الضيع اللبنانيه على العلم اللبناني
وقدمنا لرئيس الجمهوريه نعم كان وقتها
الهدف انه اكيد في هدف وطني عم نجمع لبنان
كله على فرض علم وهدف سياحي شجعنا على
السياحه الداخليه بس الهدف الاساسي كان هو
انه شهاده انه الايمان بالله واراده
الحياه اقوى من الخوف من المرض نعم
برحلتنا سالوها لبرب قالوا لها انت ما
بتستحي تقولي انه عندك سرطان انه ما
بتخافي قالت لهم بالعكس لازم كل الناس
تعرف فينا لحتى تدعمنا وتصلي لنا ام سو
المريض دائما بحاجه دائما بحاجه لهال لهال
السبورت الدعم من من يلي حوله وهو اوقات
كثير هو اللي بيعطي الدعم الاساسي على اي
حال يعني نحن البشر نعيش على الدعم في
عندما نكون بصحه تامه فما بالكم يعني لو
كنا مرضى وبحاجه لدعم اكبر اي قبل ان اعود
الى الاستديو الى النقاش سنعرض علينا
وعليكم الان ش ده لسيده اردنيه اسمها رزان
روسان يناجيه من سرطان الثدي بفضل الفحص
المبكر شقص بالمرض وكان عمرها 37 عاما
الينا واليكم
قصتها اول ما تلقيت الخبر اكيد كثير زعلت
وكثير انصدمت وبتذكر سالت الدكتوره سؤالين
جوابهم هم اللي طمنوني وخلوني ابلش واكمل
في مرحله العلاج ويكون عندي مرحله تقبل
السؤال الاول هو سالت الدكتوره ايزه كوبل
وهل هو قابل للشفاء فضمن تني بكل نعم
بنسبه 95% واكثر والسؤال الثاني اللي
سالتها اياه قلت لها انه شعري شعري رح
يوقع فطمن لي قالت لي مش بالضروره وهلا
صار في كثير حلول بديله مثل طاقيه التبريد
وغيرها وهدول الجوابين هم اللي كانوا
سلاحي لاكمل كل فتره العلاج واتقبل
الموضوع بدون معركه وحرب وهاي القصص اللي
دائما بنسمعها تجربه علاجي انا بعتبرها
تجربه ايجابيه لعده اسباب اولها بسبب
الفحص المبكر اللي عملته واللي خلاني او
سهل علي رحله علاجي ثاني شيء على قد ما
كانوا معطيني توقعات وتخويف من فتره
العلاج وشو رح يصير في ولما انا فتت
بمرحله العلاج لقيتها كثير اسهل من ما
كانوا الناس عم بيوصفوا لي وكمان بوجود
الدعم العائلي والاصدقاء وبالاخص الزوج
اللي سهل علي كثير من رحله علاجي لما يكون
في عندك دعم كثير كبير من العائله وخاصه
من الزوج كثير بتكون فتره العلاج ايجابيه
والاهم من هذا كله انه انت لازم تشتغلي
على حالك قد ايه لازم تكون نفسيتك حلوه
ويكون عندك امل كثير كبير انه فتره وبتعدي
وكل شيء عم بتمري فيه هو عباره عن اعراض
مؤقته وبتنتهي وان شاء الله بتنج من هذا
المرض وبتصيري ناجيه دكتوره ريم بكلمه
اخيره لو سمحتي اليوم ماذا تقولين للسيدات
اللواتي اصبنا
بهذه التجربه او بهذا المرض وخجلنا من
التحدث عن الامر الامراه هي الروح والروح
هي غثاء الجسد واللي اللي نحاول نشدوا فيه
اكثر حاجه هو قوه الايمان بالله خطر العمر
هو بيد الله ويلزم ديما نبث موجات ايجابيه
ونحاول نصيحه مني انا ان نبعد على كل ما
هو سلبي وكل ما هو ستريس وكل ماه اي حاجه
ك سوا انسان والا سيتسي د ستس نحاول نبعد
عليها خاطر هذاك من اكثر الحاجات اللي
تساعد على وجود
وانتشار السرطان دونك اضحكوا كلكم راكم
كلكم جميلات بالسرطان ولا بلاش سرطان
والحياه جميله جدا شكرا لك دكتوره على هذه
الرساله الايجابيه نتمنى لك الفوز
والانتصار في هذه المعركه والشفاء التام
رولا يحيى في كلمه اخيره واشكرك اصلا يعني
اعلم ان الموضوع صعب ربما عليك واشكرك على
يعني هذه القوه التي تعطيها لمن هو
حولك ماذا علمتك حربك مع
السرطان طبعا علمتني كثير
لانه يعني بالعكس اعطتني زخم اكثر لحتى لي
تابع ن ضالتي ولانه كثير يعني عندي شغلات
ونشاطات بساعد الحي
بعملي طبعا اهتم باولادي اكثر يحسوا
بوجودي كل الوقت مش انه يكون غيب كثير
عنهم كثير مهم انه يكون في كمان من يعني
اي مستشفى بدها لما بتبلش بيعلنوا للمراه
انا اللي ساعدني كمان انه الان معهد كوري
مستشفى كوري بيعملوا لنا جلسات اول ما
بيعلنوا بتقعد المرضى بتقول لنا شو رح
يصير معك بدهم يروحوا حواجبك اس باسي
لعيونك انا مثلا بنبه النساء ضروري انه
يحطوا كمان اشياء اذا التوعيه الحديث عن
عن هذه التفاصيل لكي تصبح اقل صعوبه ربما
او اقل و انه مثلا بينشف العلاجات بتنشف
الجلد ممكن تاثر مثلا حتى الانف بينزع
العينين الضفير انا مثلا ري كان يطلع لي
ضفر فوق الضفر وان وجع كثير ف هيدا كمان
بس كله طبعا له علاجات
وله يعني رولا نحن نتمنى لك كل انتصار
التام في هذه الحرب شكرا كثير شكرا كثير
طبعا في للاسف انه في كثير حوادث صعبه
بهالايام بس بضلني عم بحاول قد ما في تابع
العلاج وما وقفه لانه ضروري نضلنا موجودين
لنتابع نضالات كمان وكما قلتي رولا يعني
الح
حياه يعني يجب ان نضحي من اجل ان نبقى في
هذه الحياه وانت تضحين وتقومين نضحي من
اجلنا ومن اجلم هاني نصار ساختم معك وانت
الرجل الذي بقي الى اخر لحظه الى جانب
بربره ماذا تقول اليوم لروح بربره التي
حاربت ايضا حاربت السرطان من سرطان الثدي
الى سرطان عندما انتشر ماذا تقول لروحها
وماذا تقول لكل سيده تمر بهذه المعركه
اليوم ا يعني نحن دائما اكيد بنركز على
موضوع الكشف المبكر بس بوضع بربره كان
للاسف انه عم نكتشف المرض بطريقه كثير
متاخره ام بس مره سالوه قالوا لها انت
صليتي كثير لحتى الله يشفيك ما بتزعلي انه
الله ما شافاك قالت لهم لو شفاني كان عم
يشفيني كرمال وكرمال عائلتي بس وقت عم
بيعطيني القوه اني اعيش مرضي بالطريقه
اللي انا عم عيشه فيها رح يشفي نس كثير من
خلالي يوم بعد 10 سنين تقريبا على وفاه
بربره وتاسيسها هي اساسيه الجمعيه قبل ما
توفت بكم يوم نحن اعلنا عن اطلاق هلا مركز
لدعم مرضه السرطان سايكو سوشال سبورت يعني
الدعم النفسي والاجتماعي يلي كل شيء بتكون
بحاجه له سيده وكل مريض سرطان بلاقيه هون
كدعم له لعيلته حل فاللي انا بقول له اياه
انه مرضك ووجعك م راح لعان وانا اليوم
موجود باعلى قمه للسرطان موجود
بكاليفورنيا بالورد كانسر ليدر صمت حتى
احكي شهاده عن هذا الموضوع وفرجي العالم
كله سوا عن قصتنا وعن قصه بربره يلي وصلت
ل يلي وصلته اليوم بلبنان فانا كثير فخور
فيها و وان شاء الله هي تكون حل ما هي
فخوره في نحن فخورات وفخورون بك استاذ
هاني شكرا كثير ونحن نتمنى لك كل التوفيق
في هذه المسيره ونتمنى لكل المصابات
النجاه
والشفاء وايضا الفوز والانتصار في في هذه
الحرب على هذا
المرض تحيه لزميلتنا زميله فقدناها في
بدايه عام
2023 هي ايضا ناضلت وربحت معركه سرطان
الثدي للاسف الحياه كانت ظالمه لكنها ربما
في مكان افضل تحيه لروحها اشتقنا لك يا
فاطمه النقاش في فلك الممنوع لا نهايه
له تابعونا على فرونز كات متكال دوليه
تحياتي
[موسيقى]
a